Ya.
Jadi, melangkah ke hadapan, bit biasa
dan qubit akan jadi asas pengiraan
yang kita boleh guna untuk tangani
masalah-masalah kompleks dalam dunia ini
jadi jom kita cuba faham perbezaan antara keduanya
dan kat mana kekuatan qubit tu datang
kalau kita tengok sebelah kiri
ni cara nak gambarkan, dan kita akan guna rajah-rajah ni
sepanjang pembentangan ni untuk
tunjukkan kuasanya — kita nampak satu bulatan
dan dua titik: bila titik tu kat kutub utara
itu maksudnya sifar, bila kat kutub selatan ia satu
itulah bit klasik dua keadaan. Sekarang, qubit ialah
unit maklumat dalam dunia kuantum
dan kat sini kita dapat gambaran dengan sfera
sfera tu ada sifar, ada satu
dan kita boleh letak dia dalam keadaan superposisi
ada satu trick istimewa yang ada kat kita
bukan je kita boleh posisikan dia dalam sfera ni
tapi bayangkan setiap satu daripada ni
macam bulan kecil
yang ada dalam sfera tu, dan kita boleh putar bulan tu
jadi kat sini korang nampak
sfera bawah dah diputar sikit
sebab tu korang nampak sikit biru
dan merah jambu, dan kita boleh putar sampai habis
jadi ni pusingan seratus lapan puluh darjah
jadi kita ada konsep fasa ni, dan kuantum bagi kita
tiga kuasa super yang ada dalam qubit
iaitu kuasa superposisi
kuasa interferens
dan kuasa keliatan
jadi jom kita kupas satu-satu — prinsip superposisi sebenarnya
agak mudah nak faham
jadi bintang kat sebelah kiri
kita ada sama ada kutub utara sifar atau kutub selatan satu
dan kalau kita tambah dua keadaan tu
sekarang kita ada qubit superposisi yang ada kedua-duanya
sifar dan satu pada masa yang sama, kutub utara
dan kutub selatan. Rajah kanan pun sama
tapi sekarang kita nak buat satu trick kecik
kita nak pakai gate, quantum gate
apa yang kita buat kat sini, ingat
kita boleh ubah — kita dapat
putar bulan-bulan kecil ni kan
jadi kita dah putar seratus
lapan puluh darjah, dan sekarang kita ada satu
jadi bila kita tambah sifar tambah satu kita dapat
keadaan superposisi
tapi perasan yang ni lain
yang kat kiri kita masih ada
sifar dan satu tapi sekarang dengan keadaan yang dah diputar
untuk yang satu tu. Ni akan jadi sangat berkuasa
untuk memanfaatkan benda kedua yang memang menarik iaitu
prinsip interferens
dan ini bukan operasi yang kita boleh buat dalam dunia bit klasik
jadi kat sini dalam contoh ni kita ada
sifar dan satu kat kiri tambah
keadaan baru yang kita cipta
yang juga sifar dan satu
tapi dengan bulan yang diputar ni, bila kita buat ni
kita boleh interferenskan dua keadaan tu
dan perasan sesuatu yang sangat menarik berlaku
kita dah batalkan keadaan satu
dan kita dapat keadaan sifar je
kita buat tu sebab kita interferenskan keadaan-keadaan tu
jadi peluang seterusnya yang kita ada sekarang
adalah berapa banyak keadaan yang boleh kita cipta
dan benda yang indah dalam kuantum ni, kita boleh cipta bilangan
yang eksponen, jadi jom tengok sistem yang ada
lima qubit. Dalam kes ni kita gambarkan qubit-qubit ni
sebagai qubit bebas, korang nampak kat kiri
sifar dan satu, dan ia didarab, kita ada lima
jadi bilangan keadaan yang boleh kita cipta dalam
komputer kuantum yang digambarkan dalam sfera kat kanan
ialah dua kepada kuasa
bilangan qubit yang kita ada, dalam kes ni lima
jadi dua kepada kuasa lima ialah tiga puluh dua keadaan
jadi kita nampak tiga puluh dua bulan kecil tu
perasan dalam kes ni kita tak masukkan
sebarang fasa, semuanya merah jambu. Aspek berkuasa daripada
menggunakan sifat yang dipanggil keliatan dalam dunia kuantum
ialah kita boleh cipta keadaan
seperti yang digambarkan kat kanan
di mana kita ada gabungan merah jambu
dan biru, di mana keadaan tu tak boleh dihuraikan
sebagai hasil darab bebas daripada
lima qubit ni. Dalam kes ni
memandangkan kita ada tiga puluh dua keadaan
apa yang ni cakap kat kita sebenarnya sesuatu yang sangat mendalam